this world is not yet ready
for all that you will do
the time will come diana and
everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can
have it look like you saw ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day has passed
i don't want to be like anyone
i want to be an apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now that's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules
the answer is always more
the way i fly they will never
find us i forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i figure
uh you are but you know what i'm ready to go i
think we can do better parachute pants
yeah um does everybody parachute now
from your secret friend
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
you're becoming quite a celebrity
why's he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind eye
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
whoa this guy's crazy
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
i tell people my sister moved
out west you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
and a lot of enemies
his call signs taskmaster he controls the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but no choices
i should have come back for you
how many others are there than us
we have to go back to where it all started
so they never do that to anyone again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found
the best look to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just stay
dug and cover my plan was to drive us away
where your plan sucks
at some point we all have to choose between
what the world wants you to be and who you
and be my are
i'm done running
here's what's going to happen natasha don't slouch
i'm not slouching you're going to get the back
hunch listen to your mother oh my god all right
enough all of you i didn't say anything that's not
secret fair that david played and it pleased
the lord but you don't really care for music do
it you like this the fourth the
fifth the minor fall the major lift
the battle king composing hallelujah
i did my best it wasn't much
i couldn't feel it so i had tried to touch
i've told the truth i'll stand before the lord
i
oh
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought in how many
hells he's never fought us not us united
you know the deal successfully complete the
mission you get 10 years off your sentence
welcome to ask force x these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few days
turn around and
oh
michael i've known you since you were a child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an answer to
your disease you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this i have a
rare blood disease and i'm running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what
is it that's not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than
you already have this would be a cure
at what cost
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
and an overpowering urge to consume
blood how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease michael morbiel
got tired of doing the whole
good guy thing what's up doc
5 000 years ago kondok was a melting
pot of cultures wealth power and magic
yet most of us had nothing except for the
chains around our necks conduct needed a hero
instead they got me i did what needed
to be done and they imprisoned me for it
now five thousand years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run the reason you survived
is because you're a very uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain i was 13 i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam i started panicking
people got hurt roberto my girlfriend i burned her
iliana i killed 18 men one by one
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your
power so we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear it
makes you live through it until it kills you
who's there
we can get out of this together
you